good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that great thing that you have
inside you explode out into the world
and have a big impact so to help you on
your journey today's message is be like
water over to you Bruce Lee I said empty
your mind be formless shapeless like
water now you put water into a cup it
becomes the cup you put water into a
bottle it becomes the bottle you're
putting in a teapot it becomes the
teapot now water can flow or it can
crash be water my friend
I think to have success as an
entrepreneur there are times where you
need to be stubborn and be like ice and
then when you need to be flexible and be
like water and the key thing is
understanding the difference between the
two and knowing when to take a stand or
not and so for me the mission the values
you're one word that should be never
changing that's ice that's rigid that's
where you are stubborn on you know I'm
all about believe if you want me to not
believe in somebody if you want me to
put somebody down if I'm gonna do
something that's against my core values
but that might help further my goal I'm
not gonna do it I'm gonna be like ice I
don't want to do that because it's
against what I stand for is a human
being and I could every day right if I
wanted to have 10 million subscribers on
my youtube channel I could do it by
slamming people and attacking them and
making people fight and just trying to
create a lot of controversy that goes
against what I believe in so I am rigid
on that even though it helps me reach my
goal of increased subscriber count I'm
not gonna do it because it goes against
my core value my one word of belief so
i'm ice but with most other things as an
entrepreneur you need to be like water
you need to adjust because your
assumptions are going to be wrong
because how you think things will play
out won't play out I think too many
people are stubborn about the wrong
things which you want to be stubborn
about the mission to vision your values
that's it
everything
the direction - how how you accomplished
it will take tons of little twists and
turns and so my first business we had a
biotech software company and I spent
months working on the perfect business
plan right like the perfect business
plan from doing research and we were
really stubborn on this is how it's
gonna work
and as soon as we got to market and
tested it we realized this isn't
actually what is happening this is not
how the market cares about us and we
made some right assumptions and a lot
that weren't quite accurate and as a
result I lost a forty million dollar
deal to sell my business because I was
too late to a party because I made the
wrong assumptions because I was ice when
I should have been water
I never since that moment I've tried to
really separate the difference of the
things that I want to be ice on that
what I want to be stubborn on and only
at the highest level the mission the
vision the core values and everything
else the how the execution the way
through has to flow has to adjust based
on what the market wants and be like
water so the question they today is I'm
curious what are you on and what are you
water on leaving the comments below
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to James Brown
James thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word I really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoyed the read so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
you're gonna have to be you know
flexible and nimble in your life that's
the that's the characteristic you want
to get you don't it's not important
whether you know what the product is of
the door or what's hot and what's not or
how to execute this particular thing you
you need to learn business and you need
to learn how to question and have an
open mind you need to know the process
of thinking about things you notice how
people can go around and be an investor
in this industry turn around without
doing anything being a great investor in
another industry or some CEO one day is
running Ford Motor Company then can run
Boeing or different industries because
it's not but the most important thing is
not the particular characteristics of
the particular industry or thing it's
how to be a good CEO just like it's how
to be a present how to have presentation
skills how to be a good manager how to
be a good subordinate how to be a good
partner how to use people how to be
usable by people how you know and those
are the things that you have to learn
now you can only learn it you can't
learn it abstractly and you can't really
learn it in school you have to learn it
by doing but you have to take those
lessons and extrapolate it so you know
the things that I did in the markets you
know the markets that and the context of
even in Investment Banking advisory
those are entirely different things
thirty years ago than they are today
they're different five years ago than
they are today
so everything is oh you know talk about
time of great change yeah you know okay
every time is a time of great change and
I will tell you and the technology is
driving it you know we and you don't
know everybody always remembers getting
it right when they thought forward
because you always acquire after quired
information always affects your views
you don't remember what you used to
think and so that's just the nature of
things and the people who be successful
in their lives are the people who are
the most flexible who can absorb the
most who are open to learn and learn who
are coachable who are not too proud to
you know dig in to new things
another valuable lesson I learned was
being persistent while being flexible
lot of entrepreneurs who spend way too
much time writing a business plan rather
than really doing things as you are
continue to execute you'll find new
things you will learn new variables the
trick is to have your business plan
which only provides through the
guidelines but not the roadmap because
Ed's you are going out and doing things
in real world you will find things will
never ever turn out to be the way you
expected them when you started a
business so it's not don't try to stick
to your business plan or spend too much
time writing a business plan but learn
as you are executing on a business plan
and you will find yourself to be
successful don't plan too much
I'm does work for me didn't work frankly
don't plan too much your carrier because
what you gonna be facing in life is
probably more powerful and much bigger
than you ever imagined so if you're
following your plan you may miss a lot
of opportunity coming on the side but
you don't even look at them by say oh I
need to continue on my clam okay even
though on the side you're gonna be a
huge opportunity coming you don't look
at them so don't plan too much or be
flexible on the planning you're gonna
have a lot of ordering particularly in
the period we're getting in 2010 2020
I think gonna be a lot of transformation
coming and they're gonna be a lot of
opportunity so be flexible if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple so it
would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
you